have you shot people like this guy yes
you have he has shot innocent people go
to the Border what Stones this guy is
the biggest terrorist
ever so guys if you are somebody who
trains like me when I'm doing boxing
when I'm jogging when I'm doing
bodybuilding this can benefit you it's
[__] from Nature's Blends as you guys
know I get my honey my black seed oil
and many other supplements from them it
has 86 plus minerals including zinc
magnesium selenium f acid 59% fully lab
tested the highest in the market boost
testosterone levels Boost energy levels
and safe for men and women so check out
Nature's Blends in the description box
and enjoy it a
Yemen yeah okay who he is can we get on
camera please is this the same guy that
one Palestinian got shot in the face and
he said Nice Shot boys is this the same
guy is it the same guy yeah not a
kid
IO in the [__] face okay okay okay
shoot him in the face and you know what
shoot him in the heart too okay good
good good good a good Jihad good good
good okay it's a good it's a good start
now tell me what's the definition of
Jihadi as I said one minute ago a Jihadi
well violent Jihad is somebody that
fights the non-believer to establish an
Islamic calip the game your game is over
this is this it's over it's over it's
you got me like you got different it's a
different ball game now yeah okay this
guy he claimed this guy's a Jihadi this
guy these are the people who go to the
front line and throw stones you know
stones have you guys seen Stones before
and most of them are told you right so
to this so to this terrorist simplifies
State terrorist you've been to that
border I don't support them i f for them
on the bo I've shot those jihadis myself
serly cuz you're a terrorist have you
have you shot people like this
guy answer don't be shy don't be shy
I've SED on the Gaza ship
have you shot people like this guy yes
you have he has shot innocent people who
go to the Border let me finish let me
finish who go to the B for what for what
Stones now let me get this right yeah
this guy is the biggest terrorist ever
yeah this guy
is yeah second that the funniest thing
I've heard all [__] day you're going
to hear me again this guy's the biggest
terrorist ever yeah he's talking about
jihadis here yeah and this guy this guy
is the same guy he goes I shoot these
people who do you shoot people who come
and throw stones no I didn't say that
you are a terrorist you are a terrorist
I shoot definition of terrorism killing
innocent people political gains you are
a terrorist do you support do you
support do you support action of Israel
do you support the ACs of Israel yes
killing innocent people and kids yes
you're making that up I'm making up you
just said to me one second you just said
to me this guy you said I shoot people
like that in the heart and in the head
yeah now you're regretting it and your
cameraman is then what did you just do
what did you just
[Music]
do doubling down I Su the [__] out of
jihadis he's a j he's a he's a he's a j
now do you
support who's anybody that kills
innocent people are terrorists to me you
are a terrorist number one the ones who
run over innocent people on the bridge
are terrorists the ones who run off run
off the B are terrorists yeah you said
you shoot jihadis yeah to me to me if we
had if we had the power let me tell you
something the prophet P him spoke
harshly against these Isis comebacks the
most the prophet said if I lived at
their time I would destroy them like one
second one second the prophet PE him
said the Isis what are they called yeah
the prophet peace him said if I lived at
their time I would wipe them off the
Earth like God almighty God has
destroyed in the Old Testament Nation
yeah Prophet said I will destroy them
why because they're the biggest enemy to
Islam you know why cuz they give birth
to people like him they give birth to
him you know what they do listen listen
listen you probably read those verses
and when and like you said you shoot
these jihadis young little kids in the
heart and in the head never shot a kid
in you never shot a kid in my life did
you not say did you not say did you not
okay has Israel shot has Israel shot
Kids On the Border have they shot kids
yeah
um
thank you palan don't swear don't swear
don't swear don't swe don't terrorist is
well hold on anybody that kills innocent
people innocent kids are
terrorist Hamas namas whatever you call
it whatever you want to call it anyone
Saudi Arab whoever they are anyone that
kills innocent people are the biggest
terrorist who did he kill innocent
people s in a [__] second listen all
right if he hry if a holds a g yes if a
kid is holding a knife coming towards
you are you allowed to shoot him I would
say no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no islamically islamically we are
told very strictly that we cannot kill
innocent kids women or
how let me finish I haven't finished
however if they're running to you with a
with a gun 100% you can shoot them why
because they're going to cause more
I'm we're talking about Stones Stones
stones
that is your made up Islam okay okay
Happ okay go you tell us okay will you
final are you will you
condemn I condemn anyone that kills
innocent people be it hisbah Hamas be it
Israel be it even if it's the British
government who go and kill inoc people
who St did in Iraq 100% but you wouldn't
you wouldn't yeah you wouldn't so you
condemn I believe going to have respect
for you I believe let me tell something
youn anyone that killed innocent people
no no notah hisbah if they you innocent
people no if they do it they're wrong
simple as 100% you know what and the
best part clowns when we actually upload
this the rest of the world will judge
what you're filming these clowns when
they hear the
oh no one said I kill are okay nobody
kills kids
nobody can are you talking to the camera
talk to me I'm I'm I'm you're expressing
yourself do you believe do you believe I
believe I semitism is Right within your
community within Islam No within um
Muslim Arab yes yes yeah there is how
combat anti-Semitism in the Muslim I've
heard it I've heard it it's wrong to our
definition to our definition do you fit
in the category of these Isis scumbags
that run people over do I what do you
fit into the category cuz we we said
anyone that kills innocent people for
political reasons is a terrorist that's
definition of terrorist you fit into
that Isis fit into that never ever ever
kill an unarmed did you know I just
showed you something a guy being sh in
the face and he said good show g a gun
prove it you prove it you're looking at
the one prove it whatever
[Applause]
yeah entire three years that I served in
the IDF yeah okay and the IDF had the
strict his Rules of Engagement and you
clowns have no idea I'm going to laugh
but I'll let you finish okay yeah in the
what in the 3 years that I was there one
time I saw mistreatment of a prisoner by
soldiers who were pissed off yeah yeah
and I stood up and cracked the shits at
him and I did not accept that because I
think targeting anyone unarmed is never
acceptable I don't give a [__] what
background you come from so do you
condemn Israel well your narrative your
version if Israel do that would you
condemn them absolutely why you not
doing they are doing it what is it
they've been know for sniping they've
been killing you said to me you make
that you said to me you said to me that
guy had a gun you
said you said to me that guy had a gun
he the one who got shot here why do you
really think Israel um Israel soldiers
are going to see a man with a gun and
they're going to give send a tear gas
they're going to send the bullet what
are you talking about they will not it's
in the tear guys you know very well
he'll get sh in the head there obviously
no I haven't you have served on my
border there no way there is no way you
can shoot someone like that without them
being
a they're hot why you why you
stuttering you're telling operations of
the idea all these kids journalist
you're King journalist man what you
talking about journalist you K
journalist like it's Happy Days man
don't try it when I finish this I'm
going to go cuz I need to pray okay yeah
yeah got I'll give the last words to you
okay what I'm going to say is a lot of
people come and say you know thear does
this let me the Shar does that the Shar
does this okay this is this is the
Jewish people who lived under the
Islamic real Islamic State not
the real RAB of
Ed Isaac tar that's his name this is why
he sounds very Jewish sound you you can
check it tarat or something like that
yeah he's wrote a letter he says here in
the land of the church we have nothing
to complain of we pres great fortunes
much gold and silver are in our hands we
are not oppressed with our heavy taxes
and our Commerce is free and unhindered
Rich are the fruits of the earth
everything is cheap and every one of us
live in Peace and Freedom here the Jew
is not compelled to wear a yellow hat as
a badge of Shame as in the case of
Germany where even wealth and great
Fortune are there you go you know what
this is this is a Jewish person living
under Islamic country
say come and live here created it's been
a pleasure goodbye any more questions
I'm going to go pray when I come back
I'm going to pray for everybody and my